quelqu'un connait c'est vrai que c'est
dire que c'est quelqu'un très bien
pourtant ça fait des semaines et des
semaines
rappelez vous que je vous parle la boîte
du club oui la banque du coeur c'est
pour aider les plus démunis
et c'est vrai que après la l'épisode des
gilet jaune
j'ai rencontré plein de gens et qui
était en détresse et je me suis tourné
vers un ami qui s'appelle le mouloud
voilà vous connaissez et qui m'a
présenté un garçon exceptionnel qui
s'appelle ya deux moulins noires soul et
vous présenter ce soir parce que c'est
lui qui a développé tous le projet qui
ne s'appellera plus longue du coeur mais
mon ami poteau est tellement de gens
m'ont demandé où on en était que ce soir
ryad et là c'est un type exceptionnel il
est beaucoup plus intelligent que moi je
lis pour ça c'est pas difficile et il
est beaucoup plus sérieux et c'est lui
qui a monté tout le projet et je
voudrais qu'on accueille ryad qui va
tout nous raconter et vous pouvez lui
poser plein de questions même sur
twitter même vous ici il ya de la loire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
puis les séries déjà c'est un génie
j'vous l'dit ya aussi regarde tu peux
nous expliquer déjà ce que tu as fait
parce que pour les gens c'est vrai que
voilà en fait ya un an c'est toi tu vas
voir tu m'a dit je veux faire une banque
du coeur et j'étais tendu je t'ai dis
c'est quoi la banque du coeur tu m'a dit
j'aimerais voilà je chemise gilet jaune
moi le soir je rentre chez moi je me
fais livrer je sais que il galère c'est
200 balles c300 balcer voilà c'est ça
qu'il faut les sortir et j'aimerais bien
avoir une banque qui soit capable de
donner et je vais arrêter tout de suite
et je t'ai dit tu sais ne va pas durer
longtemps aventure parce qu'ici on
commence à donner à tous ceux qui ont
des problèmes
on est dix millions de personnes qui
sont dans la qui sont en précarité tout
leur donne un euro sans rien changer de
leur vie et en a perdu 10 millions
d'euros
donc on ne peut pas se permettre de
donner de l'argent si on regarde pas
l'écossé quelles sont les causes qui
sont qui aurait pu ramener ça et donc
j'ai commencé un travail de longue
haleine sur lequel je me suis dit
comment la gère à la misère en france
j'ai regardé il ya un million huit
d'association il y en à 1887 reconnue
d'utilité publique c'est une jungle vous
savez pas par où commencer
voilà je me suis dit la première chose
qu'on va faire c'est qu'on va faire un
point unique un point unique d'entrée et
on va utiliser toute la technologie
aujourd'hui les technologies nous
permettent pour savoir c'est quoi votre
problème et ce qui est un problème de
logement est ce que c'est un problème de
salubrité
est ce que c'est un problème d'emploi ce
qu'ils s'imprègnent de deux formations
est ce que c'est un problème de violence
voilà et on va utiliser toute la
technologie pour pouvoir déjà s'appuyer
sur ces 1887 associations qui sont
reconnues d'utilité publique donc on va
on va guider
parce que forcément le problème de
l'argent n'est souvent que le symptôme
c1 le le le manque d'argent n'est qu'un
n'est qu'un symptôme au racing beaucoup
de plus multiple que ce qu'on croit et
donc ici on regarde pas ça dans son
ensemble on va pas faire du bien comment
dit on va donner un poisson
donc quand je suis remonté là dessus je
me suis dit aujourd'hui on a déjà 1885
qui existe il ya aussi des acteurs que
vous avez déjà fait venir ici des start
up de l'inclusion de natural comme il
dit que vous avez fait venir
il ya beaucoup de choses qui existent il
ya aussi des trucs de formation il ya
aussi lente war on va prendre la
personne dans son ensemble on va la
diagnostiquer et on va lenval l'orienter
on va pas faire que ça on va l'orienter
et on va mesurer
on va la suivre on va vérifier que ça
marche bien on va vérifier qu'on les a
bien orienté et on va voir en profiter
pour financer les associations tous ceux
qui sont sur le terrain il est vrai
qu'ils pensent toutes les plaies de la
société elle a laissé cela on va aller
on va les mettre en valeur
on va les rémunérer et c'est ça mon ami
poteau voilà c'est ça mon ami poteau on
est capable de conseiller alors poteau
sincère est un robot c'est un robot
serpent qui l'a conçu voilà c'est un
robot il vous parle il est sympa il
parle comme cyril il faut y voi pa café
moi j'en bois c'est un robot c'est ce
qu'on appelle les potes aujourd'hui il
va vous parler ils vous parlent comme
cyril vous fait des blagues il déconne
on va faire une interview comme une
assistante sociale le ferai mais ce
qu'on va pas la faire de façon
dégradante
on va pas la faire de façon humiliante à
la sphère façon sympa et on va détecter
ce qui se passe et à partir de là on va
s'appuyer sur déjà ce qui existe et ce
qui n'existe pas on ira l'inventer et
s'il ya besoin on sera capable soit
donné de l'argent soit de le prêter soit
de cautionner soit toi fournir des
garanties et ces [ __ ] et c'est ça
l'univers regarde il a fait un travail
excellent puisque mon avis poteau c'est
un robot incroyable parce que grâce à ce
que vous lui voulu livrer bon il ya une
discussion et vous il va pouvoir tout de
suite
localisé il vos besoins et vous orienter
vers ce qui pourrait vous faire du bien
ce qui pourrait vous aider ses seins
riad et c'est vrai que si vous avez des
questions n'hésitez pas à me dire et que
riyad avec son bien est ce que vous avez
déjà audité vous savez à peu près lequel
montant vous avez besoin pour être
efficace dans un premier temps pour
toutes ces associations jeu vraiment il
est au mieux je vais vous dire on va
voir on va avoir besoin de beaucoup ça
c'est clair on va avoir besoin de
beaucoup
aujourd'hui ce que je suis con dépenses
que chacun chaque euro qui sera investi
dans mon ami poteau soit utilisé
efficacement
je veux savoir où il va et exactement
tisseyre contrat cela c'est exactement
ça la traçabilité et pour ça vous allez
être hyper sollicités on connaît la
misère des gens comment vous allez au
départ sélectionné ce que vous allez
aimer en premier déjà encore une fois on
partait de zéro je voulais pas monter
une année à l'association comme je
voulais dit on à déjà 1887 on va déjà
faire avec ce que vous avez des services
publics aussi qu'il existe
vous avez des sites d'information qu'il
existe également le problème se tiend
jungle quand vous êtes aujourd'hui dans
la galère comme on dit vous savez pas
par où commencer
et généralement vous attendez le dernier
moment souvent quand il est trop tard
vous allez attendre le moment où la
maison brûle pour dire attendez j'ai
besoin d'être
que je veux c'est déjà de détecter avant
on est déjà capable de conseiller avant
de dire on va donner on est déjà capable
de conseiller on est capable de
réorienter il ya des choses qui se font
énormément sur la formation sur l'emploi
mais également sur les violences vous en
parlait souvent dans ma mission
les violences le harcèlement pour les
mineurs voilà on peut retrouver
énormément de choses on va arriver par
un point juste d'interface et on va
pouvoir dispatcher c'est comme meilleur
taux plein comme sa mère elle pas comme
c'est à peu près ça qu on aime et
associations par association servat le
but
et voilà et qui a des outils financiers
qui va mettre ses outils financiers à la
disposition des associations pour
pouvoir réellement régler les problèmes
donc on fait un don à manille poteau qui
valurent redistribuées c'est même un peu
plus parce qu'on va même créé une crypto
monnaie maintenant on parle beaucoup de
blocs chaîne d'être une fois on va faire
la blague chaîne de la solidarité
on va créer une crypto monnaie vous
pourrez ça s'appellera des poteaux les
associations y gagneront des poteaux les
bénévoles qui bosseront pour ces
associations pourront être également
poteau on va mettre une référence
on va dire qu'un poteau il ya une
journée de bénévolat et à partir de là
une fois qu'on aura acheté ça on va
faire une monnaie de la solidarité et on
n'aura plus qu'à acheter ça pour voir
les redistribuer mais complètement
montrer concrètement à quel stade alors
aujourd'hui on a tous les partenariats
avec le monde associatif mais pas que
associatif a également privé il ya
l'entreprise est allé il ya des sites
d'emploi il ya tout ça donc là on est en
plein un partenariat on a le partenaire
financier on a tous acquis et backup et
on à la technologie est prête à
l'écologie pour est également de la
technologie est vrai qu'après beaucoup
de temps voilà donc on sera on sera
capable de de commencer au premier
trimestre 2001 et pourtant il est fini
c'est fini mais sénia vous pouvez pas
être que deux sur projet est ce que vous
avez déjà des belles voitures et de
valeurs je suis également en relation
s'il ya des personnes qui sont
intéressées pour vous aider aussi
choisir avec plaisir et moi ce que moi
mon idée c'est de fédérer tout doucement
la toux ceux qui ont envie que ça bouge
j'en peux plus de voir des gamins dormir
accords et des distributeurs de billets
moi ma vie elle va bien donc je pense à
vis aussi et va bien et je pense qu'on a
une obligation sinon à devoir céder au
moins de penser à ces gars-là est
décimée et faire quelque chose pour ces
services qui sera uniquement disponible
en ligne
oui les mobiles web mobile complètement
ligne vous aurez juste une
vous rentrez dans une petite
conversation comme une interview vous
avez l'impression que c'est une vraie
personne qui vous parle et puis voilà on
va vous demander gentiment qu'est-ce que
vous avez des enfants ça se passe bien
ce qui vous êtes en sécurité
est ce que vous vous travaillez en ce
moment est-ce que vous avez besoin de
formation enfin voilà on va gentiment
offert sa bernard et illégalement c'est
l'ancien huissier qui parle vous êtes
comment juridiquement ces notations j'ai
un cerveau tu as une forme dotation
c'est un fonds de dotation c'est à dire
que tout l'argent qui est mis dans le
sens de stations nous doit servir que la
mission pour laquelle il offre donc on
va pas pouvoir partir avec la caisse est
désolé pour l'instant la princesse haya
que c'est nous c'est nous justement
c'est important comment faire alors pour
l'instant comarmond l'année avec ryad
pour l'instant tu crois que nous on veut
pas demandé enfin vous demandez qu'on
compte d'entreprises des dons et nous
faire des dons nous mêmes on peut alors
on le fera et quand on va lancer la
crypto monnaie vous aurez complètement
la possibilité vous de pouvoir acheter
un poteau et à chaque fois que vous
achèterez un poteau c'est comme si vous
achetiez une journée d'un bénévole dans
une association dont vous aurez cette
possibilité là et c'est ça qui sera
redistribuée et vous pouvez également à
l'ensemble des unités et est aussi une
dimension si le caution aussi pour les
gens voilà ça c'est bien que personne ne
prête de l'argent ça c'est le but qui
doit pas prêter si les autres savent
déjà prêté sa sert à rien on va faire on
va être content non le but c'est qu'on
puisse prêter à ceux à qui on croit plus
près de plaintes qui ont pré plus et si
on n'a pas de choix
et si le prêt parce qu'on veut du prêt
responsable ça sert à rien de prêter à
quelqu'un s'il est pas capable de
rembourser
et ben non un comme été décidée ce qui
décidera ou non de données est-ce que
six mois alors il ya des gens qui
veulent donner des x 10 20 euros ils
peuvent pas donner plus maison à savoir
faire par exemple il ya un plombier un
artisan un peintre est ce que ces gens
là pourront venir se greffer à ce projet
par exemple moi je vais donner aussi
parce que je peux me permettre mais j'ai
un permis poids lourd est ce que je
pourrais moi participer aussi à faire
des choses est ce que le gone le
plombier pourra vous aider le maxus que
je vous conseillerais là dessus c'est de
vous rapprocher de toutes les
associations partenaires à qui vous
pourrez prêter votre camion à faire du
transport ou des choses comme ça car me
prêtez votre camion prêté
d'un côté une trottinette tu parlais de
près des fois on auprès des foyers des
prêts de plomberie ou de maçonnerie
s'apprêter 2000 euros est ce qu'il n'ya
pas quelqu'un qui peut venir rejoindre
dire moi je le fais pour mon poto
complètement ouvert mais tous ceux qui
veulent aider et qui veulent en finir
avec cette galère ils sont les bienvenus
on fera un prime spécial en direct dans
la rue avec les hyades bas ce sera dos
au premier trimestre 2001 pour lancer
mon avis et vous ferez la connaissance
de mon ami poteau voilà qu'on présentera
en vrai nom on l'a déjà vu ce qui dort à
la maison et je voudrais qu'on
applaudisse tréport ya fait
com
regarde ce dernier mot à dire peut-être
voilà un bon voilà parce que si j'ai
besoin de tout le monde
j'ai besoin de tout le monde alors que
toutes les bonnes volontés tous ceux qui
pensent à alesi venez on a besoin il
faut convaincre ceux qu'il faut qu'on
ait des problèmes de ce pays pour
convictionnels de voir l'intérêt de
voter sont les bienvenus c'est sympa de
nous rendre utiles moi je trouve c'est
clair non enfin on se sent inutile là on
se sent trahi il avait donc tu en
visibilité en tournée peu voilà j'ai
besoin de moyens
[Applaudissements]